le statu quo n'est pas acceptable estime
le directeur national de santé publique
le bois l'eau la fonderie horne de rouyn
noranda doit réduire ses émissions
d'arsenic le plus rapidement possible
soyons très clairs
pour moi le métier des actions
personnelles
il ne s'avance toutefois pas sur les
exigences qui doivent être imposées à la
fonderie horne une déception pour
plusieurs citoyens et médecins qui
réclame l'imposition de la norme
provinciale de 3 nanogrammes par mètre
cube d'arsenic dans l'air on aurait aimé
ça qu'il prononce plus fermement avec un
des chiffres clairs puis vraiment on
aurait souhaité le trône à g
effectivement pour l'art ce n'est qu' on
aurait voulu céder les chiffres pour les
autres métaux lourds les autres
contaminants on a aussi plein d'autres
contaminants qui on n'a pas regardé non
plus la synergie antique aux
contaminants parce que c'est c'est pour
un plus un qui fait double c'est un plus
un qui fait peut-être cinq ce qu'on
entend beaucoup ces kits qui est
acceptable comme norme pour les gens de
rouyn
moi mon questionnement c'est pourquoi
est ce que quelque chose d'autre que la
norme serait acceptable pour les jambes
rejoint la santé publique prévoit faire
d'autres études et réclamer d'autres
avis d'expert dans les prochaines
semaines un délai qui n'est pas
nécessaire croit le député solidaire de
rouyn noranda témiscamingue on détient
assez d'informations en ce moment pour
prendre des décisions
je pense que les citoyens sont déçus
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils s'attendent à
être assurée par l'avenue du docteur
boileau mais on n'a rien appris de neuf
on n'a pas de plan b on n'a pas de plan
d'action on n'a pas de plan de match
tous les yeux sont maintenant tournés
vers clean power propriétaire de la
fonderie horne la multinationale estime
qu'elle devrait investir près d'un demi
milliard de dollars dans ses
installations pour réduire ces émissions
le chef des opérations cuivre amérique
du nord claude bélanger qui s'exprimait
pour la première fois dans le dossier
admet que l'entreprise devra être plus
transparentes c'est clair pour nous avec
la situation qu'on voit présentement
c'est clair qu'en comme les bonnes
fréquences qui est acceptable pour les
citoyens les citoyens ont beaucoup de
questions c'est tout à fait normal et
nous on va se mettre on se met en
mouvement on va vraiment communiquer de
manière beaucoup plus fréquentes
transparent des gens voient en mesure de
voir l'avancement des projets tout ça
arrive au moment où glencore négocie
présentement avec québec non seulement
pour obtenir une aide financière pour
moderniser ses installations mais aussi
pour renouveler son attestation
d'assainissement attestation qui lui
permet présentement d'émettre jusqu'à 33
fois la norme québécoise d'arsenic dans
l'air il sait annie-claude luneau radio
canada rouyn noranda